hello everyone and welcome back to the
coverage of the world rabbit
championship it's a game from round 11
first game of round 3 Maxine Varsha
lagravis is magnus carlsen a very
important game as well everyone's just
been waiting to see how MV l will do
against Magnus and well with everything
that's been going on lately never will
and vo being the candidate will and will
not be in the candidates it's just a
very important game and especially they
the two of them are battling it out to
see who will come on top as the number
one the highest rated rapid player in
the world and also some two hours before
this game started I created a poll on
Twitter asking you guys who do you think
will win and well here are the results
of the poll you know 17 nine point seven
percent of you said that Magnus crossing
whirlwind and 20.3% said that Maxime
Vash Alegre will win and 688 of you have
voted so those are the predictions now
let's see what actually happened in the
game and Maxime for sure log of opens
with E 4 which means he's challenging
Magnus to his World Chess Championship
preparation Magnus goes for his Sicilian
sorry about that
we have Knight to f3 by Maxime Knight to
c6 and d4 now we have characters captors
Knight to f6 we have Knight to c3 and
now of course he 5 pushing the knight
back like he did during the World Chess
Championship match against the Fabiana
Caruana
night BB 5 and we have d6 now allowing
Knight to d5 with Knight to d5 by maksim
now threatening knight c6 check so
Magnus trades of one of the Knights
Knight captures pawn captures in the
knight to e7 we have see for
strengthening the at the center here and
Knight back to g6 now weave Queen to a4
now threatening some nasty discoveries
Bishop to d7 preventing them and Queen
to b4 now and the Queen to b8 if you
remember during the World Chess
Championship match we used to discuss
how this is some insane super engine
preparation stuff and they go straight
into it with h4 by Maxine h5 by Magnus
and here Bishop e3 was played by Fabiana
Caruana in game 14 that's second game of
the rapid of the world
championship match 2018 that magnus
carlsen one and also a van forest tried
to this Bishop to e3 idea against Magnus
Magnusson also won that game but here we
have Bishop to d3 and by mvl and it is
as of move 13 that we have a completely
new game so what's the idea and the
threat is of course just capturing the
knight here which would severely [ __ ]
black's pawn structure and the Magnus
instantly replies with a six which means
he's well within his World Chess
Championship preparation and now Knight
back to c3 you don't have time to snap
off the night because just a capture Sun
beasts on b5 your bishop is under attack
you have to move it the Shabak and now
after characters captures you get b5 in
and blacks fault
all of his problems it's just a
beautiful position for black so you have
to go back Knight c3
maxime also knows this as he is also
well within his preparation all of these
moves have been played pretty much
instantly now there is a threat of
Bishop captures night so f5 expanding
and it does look a bit dangerous but you
know it's well within the preparation
with Bishop to e3 and Bishop to e7
Magnus prepares the Castle kingside
with Knight to a4 now with insane
control of the of the b6 square Queen to
c7 and now Knight to b6 attacking the
rook and is just a very nice outpost for
the night we have looked to d8 by Magnus
and g3 now for the moment prepare
preventing f4 and E for now something
I've seen the Magnus to do this already
in structures like these you just you
know free up the e5 square for the
knight and the knight will have a
beautiful outpost in the center of the
board but for back the e2 and now Knight
to e5 and here without giving it a
second thought
in VL Castle queenside
saying that I am still well within my
preparation and I'm not afraid of of any
open file that may soon you know become
open
we have castles by Magnus also instantly
and now there's the question of the h5
pawn can it be captured not really
because if you capture this then you're
giving up the c4 pawn and if
you know nice captures the king is still
on c1 so b5 will easily win back the
piece so we have Kings to be 1 by n VL
and now the shop eh guarding the pawn
but also preparing to transfer bishop to
these diagonals you know depending on
which one will prove more useful rook
the c1 our maxim now prepares the other
rook to enter the game and also now he
would like to push c5 and c6 at some
point we push up to g6 now putting the
bishop on this diagonal could be also
very useful if the position opens up
some f4 you know if it happens so kink
the a1 getting the King to a more safer
Square and the Magnus goes King to h7
also the King will be much safer there
we have rook H to d1 getting this rook
into the game and rook F to e 8 by
Magnus if once the e-file clears up and
for example if F 4 is played you do want
your EB for point to be defended with
Knight to a4 now with more support for
c5 but also just threatening to win
material with Bishop to b6 so rook the
c8 by Magnus and here the situation on
the clock is 12 and a half minutes
Maxime 14 at 14 minutes and 40 seconds
for Magnus so pretty much neither of
them wasting any time up until this
position we have Queen to b6 Maxime
offers a queen trade and Magnus of
course doesn't go for this if captures
captures then that's just a beautiful
night black doesn't really have any any
good ideas here what black wants to do
is keep the Queen's on the board which
is what Magnus does he goes Queen back
to b8 and now we have Queen back to b3
also there was there was the very
interesting idea that after this rook
the c8 instead of this there is the
option of night to just back to b6 and
here I'm very interested to see that
well we can't really see but would we
see a repetition of movie or night if
for Luke c8 night back here so I don't
know but it would be it would be
interesting to see because this is super
preparation so if this is what the
position calls for maybe it's just you
know and then
Ceri but okay rook c8 like I said Queen
b6 Magnus declines Queen to be eight and
now Queen back to be three Maxime wants
the freed the d1 square for the Queen
and the Queen Bishop battery to go for
the h5 pawn but Magnus is not really
worried about this he just plays Bishop
to f6 now puts both of the bishops on
very nice diagonals so for the moment
they're doing nothing but if the
position opens up you are looking at a
potential bishop pair from hill here so
now it's time to strike
we have c5 and Magnus now goes back with
the Bishop Bishop to f7 not allowing the
advancement of the pawn to c6 because
after cap sorry
because after captures you will not be
able to capture due to the pin so nice
to be six once again and here we have
rook C back to d8 by Magnus we look to
d2 now preparing to remover the Queen to
go after the h5 pawn and now Magnus
captures at D captors and c5 with Bishop
Tadros on c5 and now Knight to d7
preparing to start trading of the pieces
the bishop is under attack so Buster
back to e3 Magnus trades here we have
Knight captures Bishop captures and rook
to d7 now the rooks are safe here since
there is no Bishop to b5 or something
like that and we have Queen to d1 now
and here the situation is nine minutes
for Maxime twelve minutes for Magnus so
still no not even close to any sort of
time trouble and here the h5 pawn is
under attack but the the way you know
Magnus played the next move so quickly
that although I don't think he's still
within his preparation um he's very well
aware of the motives and motives that
can arise in positions like the DS so
here he played Queen to e5 for the you
know I'm just gonna show Luke to see it
because it's also very nice it prevents
Bishop captures and h5 due to attack if
you capture it and then just you know
rook captures here Quinn captures and
you will lose the bishop so even if
captures captures the bishop is still
off-limits because here you just kick
the bishop back with g6 Bishop to e2 and
now rook captures on d5 and now of
course after Luke chapter
special characters you are unable to
capture it due to this mate on c1 so by
playing king day one it is a safe square
for the king unless the position really
opens up then you have back rank issues
so we have Queen to d1 rook to see it
interesting but Magnus goes for Queen to
e5 which is very scary because well if
the rook moves from d2 that's a mate
their own b2 so here again it prevents
you from capturing on h5 because again
we have this g6 Bishop to e2 and now
just rook captures on d5 and now you
cannot capture due to mate so it's just
not worth giving up the h5 pawn grabbing
the h5 phone for this mighty d5 pawn so
after Bishop e5 we have Bishop back to
c4 and now it's questionable whether
this whole Queen b3 to d1 going after
the h5 point was worth it because the
bishop is now forced to guard the d5
pawn and now f4 by Magnus and all of a
sudden it does seem like Magnus is
dictating zone of the battle since well
you you are forced to make a good reply
here so mvl decides that he doesn't like
all this pressure rushing back to d4 of
forces the trade of dark square bishop
Queen to f5 and adjust Bishop captures
an f6 we have Queen captures on f6 and G
captures an f4 now Magnus captures on f4
and now you do want to keep your your
pawn
safe here so d6 advancing it even
further and not interested in trading
this bishop here and allowing white to
even improve his position further with
the rook captures in rugby fruit Brooke
d4 we have Bishop back to g6 now here
the shabak the e2 now again with threats
of going for the h5 pawn but just rook e
to d8 Magnus now says okay you grab this
point I'm gonna go for the d6 pawn and
since you cannot add another defender to
the d6 pawn MVL goes for it we have
captures and now before reacting to the
pawn the first bishop to f5 you just
want to keep your bishop safe to guard
the e4 pawn and here the situation on
the clock is 7 minutes in VL 8 minutes
and 40 seconds Magnus
so here you the problem is after all the
trades are made on these six you have
the problem that your rook and C 1 will
be unguarded especially if the Queen
captures on d6 so Queen to e1 not
allowing that after captures and
captures your queen on d1 will be under
attack so here at Magnus just picks up
his pawn rook captures rook captures we
have rook captures and now Bishop it
back to e 2 so here the material on the
board is equal however Magnus has a move
that wins the game in this position so
feel free to pause the video and try to
find it it's not an easy move to find
well perhaps it's an even even an
impossible move to find but you know you
are you know you're not under under
pressure of the clock you are in your
home you know or maybe on your mobile
phone yeah you know enjoying yourself so
take all the time you need and try to
find this sneaky idea well I give you a
couple of seconds so for those of you
who were able to do it congratulations
and finding such such a beautiful
supercomputer move and for those of you
who just want to enjoy the show its rook
the d2 it's really really well we
shouldn't expect anyone to not to find
such a move because it's not at all
clear what what it does what it does is
that it prevents white from actually
making any moves you cannot move the
bishop because you lose the f2 point you
cannot move the Queen anywhere you lose
the bishop and you don't really have any
good moves with the rook for example one
one nice variation that shows just how
silly the position is is if you offer a
rook trade then just the rook captures
on d1 and the official captures a queen
to c1 is made since the Queen no longer
covers the the back rank and if you
capture with the Queen then just Queen
captures on f2 you grab a pawn and you
have a past
eeep on its winning position now so
really really tough move to find and
perhaps Magnus would have found it but
he went for Queen to d2 instead he
decided that this endgame was winning
for black but he missed one very
important detail here nvl plays a3 he
gets rid of his back ranked weaknesses
we have Queen captures an e1 rook
captures and not rooked
to a very active move with the rook and
now crossings plan is to stick this
Bishop over to b3 and to completely
dominate the Queen side were and
hopefully Elvia will not have a very
useful move to play so King to a2 we
have Bishop to e6 but now mvl has King
to be one with Bishop to b3 and now kink
the c1 and this is what Magnus missed
otherwise he would have spent more time
he had a lot of time so he might even
come up with that rook to d2 move but
here the problem is bishop the d1 is
coming and white will be able to trade
everything and then he just has a more
active King so here cousin goes rook see
to check you cannot go here as the
bishop covers that so King b1 and rook
the c6 and going after the age for pawn
but now it's a bishop to d1 you cannot
allow this powerful the shop to remain
here we have Bishop captures rook
captures and now Luke to h6
going after the h4 points so now it's
basically a rock endgame rook d7 going
after the b7 pawn b5 and King see two
Maxima now starts improving the position
of his king rook captures on h4 kinked
at b2 now again improving the position
of the King you are down upon but it's
it's a row component game so you should
be able to hold it we looked the f4
going after the pawn kinki kinki to
defending king h6 and now rook to e7
going after the point we have rook to f6
rook to e7 now going after this pawn and
maxime shows that he will constantly be
going back and forth between the pawns
and here at Magnus just played rook the
c6 and it was in this position that the
players agreed to a draw since well now
it really is a draw for example a rope
captor is only for Roxy to check and all
the pawns get traded King f3 you're
gonna go captures rook II 6 check King
wherever look captors here and it's a
two points each a drone rook rook and
game so really exciting stuff after rook
to c6 they agreed to a draw but this was
the magical moment after the shop - e -
Magnus mr. rook to d2 and it's just well
a big big a big well opportunity missed
not only for for taking down and bail
but also for
you know cementing his number-one rapid
player in the world but also for getting
closer to winning the world rapid
championship but that's just what you
get when you face him vo he went
straight into cousins Watchers
championship preparation play that
played a really impressive game but in
the end it wasn't enough and almost
almost lost the game so that's the game
I do hope you enjoyed it I would like to
thank Michael Carey Pete spawn robots a
Victor client a David Raskin and Fredrik
zero for a contribution to my channel
thank you a lot I really appreciate it
as usual you can check two of my
previous videos here thank you for
watching and I will see you soon
continuing the coverage of the feed a
world rapid championship and for the
next few next two days the feeder world
blitz championship sir thank you I will
see you soon and have an excellent rest
of you Lee